Welcome to Hong Kong: An incredible density of Chinese island cities with a population of 7 million
But if you, a traveler, from Victoria Harbour to the mainland,
You will find that Hong Kong is China, but she does not look like it.
If you want to enter, your passport must be inspected, stamped, checked, and stamped.
Not because you are very suspicious: mainland Chinese cannot go directly.
Just because Hong Kong has her own immigration policy.
And Hong Kong is not the only isolated island, next door to Macau.
The border and port also need a passport. If you are departing from Hong Kong
Go to Macau, then the mainland, come back. You will be stamped three times, everyone is the same:
Hong Kong people cannot live in Macau directly in Macau.
They also cannot live directly on the mainland.
Although they belong to China, and the troublesome travel is not the only special thing about these sister islands.
They also have:
* Different governments and political parties. * Different police officers.
* Different currencies. * Postal system.
* School. * and language.
Hong Kong even has her own Olympic team fighting a pain in the 2008 Beijing Olympics.
It seems like.. Nothing.. Isn't it right?
The only one of these sister islands is not, but what other countries have is:
1) Your own army.
Although this is nothing special for modern countries, there are...
2) Formal diplomatic relations.
Although these are a bit messy, because both are members of the international trade organization.
And other countries have embassies in Hong Kong and Macau. Of course China will not recognize them as embassies.
Those are limited to **mighty Beijing** -- they are called "consulates"
Although they are bigger than the embassy in Beijing.
All of this makes Hong Kong and Macau, as I said in the previous video:
The most country-like countries that are the countries in the world - not the country - the most country-like countries that aren't countries.
Then why are they called China?
Because China said.
This is called "one country, two systems".
I think it should be called "one country, three systems".
(In that unimpeded development of capitalism) makes it more like "one country, four systems"
And if China is embarrassed, it may become "one country, five systems."
We can't cover so much content, so we go back to China, Hong Kong and Macau.
The reason why China has these two city-states is as usual, because of the empire.
Portugal appeared in Asia in the 1500s but was not friendly with China. China and Portugal
Continued clashes until Portugal used a lot of money in diplomatic methods to bribe local Chinese officials
Make the island of Macau a trading port.
After that, Great Britain discovered China, and at the same time she found many things she wanted, such as silk.
Porcelain, and treasures - the much-needed tea in Great Britain. In turn, China wants Great Britain
Rolling for Laozi~ Great Britain recognizes China’s independence and sovereignty.....
Wait!!
Crow ~ film ~ war ~ fight ~!
Nothing can produce more demand than addiction. Great Britain is happy to offer. And through
Artillery diplomacy ensures that Hong Kong is used as a base because it must maintain drug circulation.
Then, in a world where telegraphs and light bulbs are very novel. A contract will take ownership of Hong Kong.
Give Great Britain 99 years or say "and never difference", kick the transfer problem to
The unimaginable future generation of the 1990 generation came to deal with.
In this way, these sister cities grew up under the influence of their empire’s parents.
Hong Kong has the common law of the United Kingdom and belongs to the structure of Great Britain like other colonies.
And Macau has the civil law of Portugal.
And the influence of their parents can still be seen today: Visiting Hong Kong will find that she is obviously the daughter of Great Britain.
Her owner's love of the economy and international finance (laser!) and British accent
There is exactly the same transportation system.
Macau has more troublesome puberty because her sister has taken all the highlights through trade.
But Macau eventually grew into the gambling capital of the world.
She is 10 times that of Las Vegas and is a hybrid of China and Portugal.
But the empire will eventually die out, and the 1990s will eventually come, meaning that the contract of Great Britain has expired.
Portugal claims that the treaty gives her *indefinite* control over Macau but China does not agree
The attitude of the United Nations is "I don’t think of an empire," and if Portugal complains too much,
China can use its own war diplomacy to solve problems.
So the transfer will still happen: but the world is nervous about China,
Because *can't erase the communist* these, so these daughters of the empire will go
But they must basically remain independent, China agrees, as long as other countries
Call them China.
This situation is a bit like if the United States wants to return Alaska to Russia.
And Russia* absolutely* guarantees Alaska government autonomy. You can't blame the local people for being nervous.
However, unlike what you think, most of China guarantees the independence of these sister islands.
So everything is fine...
*however*...
Handover has its own version of the 'and never difference' clause
China has not agreed to let Hong Kong and Macau* be forever * independent, but only 50 years
So once again, the political issue is handed over to future generations. (I hope this time is really impossible to futify the phenomenon).
In any case, it is irrelevant to assume that these indifferent concerns are singular.
What will happen in 2040? Will Hong Kong and Macau maintain a small city state?
Or will they lose their independence and be absorbed?
Only China knows, but China will not say it.